[Música]
por muchos años hemos asociado a la
tecnología con aquellas grandes
innovaciones o artefactos que de alguna
u otra manera han venido a facilitar y
por qué no a transformar nuestra vida en
todos los sentidos
y de alguna manera hemos sido
aleccionados a contemplar la
magnificencia de la tecnología como un
fenómeno externo como algo que ha de
ocurrir allá afuera
como humanidad hemos cerrado y hoy
quiero contarte por qué
hemos creado todo un misterio sobre qué
hay detrás de la tecnología
creyendo que
sugerido producir tecnología es tarea de
unas cuantas personas superdotadas
quiero contarte que el concepto de la
tecnología proviene de la antigua grecia
y nace de dos vocablos technet que
significa arte belleza
manifestación y logos estudio y
desarrollo de algo es así como el
concepto filosófico de la tecnología se
refiere al desarrollo de la capacidad
que posee el ser humano de manifestar
algo
acá es cuando
la robótica la cripto moneda la
inteligencia artificial se convierten en
lo manifestado en el producto creado de
la tecnología del ser humano de su poder
de manifestación
sabías que la tecnología biológica más
impresionante es el cuerpo humano
12 sistemas
sincronizados entre sí para lanzarnos a
la vida sostenernos y capacitarnos para
la coexistencia
sobrevivencia y evolución
12 sistemas que se actualizan según las
necesidades del entorno
12 sistemas que reconociéndose en cada
uno de sus elementos
células tejidos órganos interactuando
entre sí con el entorno cumplen su
misión de mantenernos con vida
y este modelo biológico no es nada más
que una muestra de lo que el ser humano
puede ser por cuenta propia no se
recuerda que el arte de hacer tecnología
no es un privilegio para unos pocos no
sus procesos y sus códigos nos han
acompañado siempre custodiados por
nuestro adn y esperando a ser activados
a esto se referían los griegos cuando
hablaban sobre technet y logos
sostenían la idea de las personas
lanzándose al viaje introspectivo
reconociéndose en cada uno de sus
talentos para luego expresar su
existencia a través de ellos
entendiendo esto es más fácil hacernos a
la idea de expresarnos tecnológicamente
hablando a través del talento por
ejemplo alguien que descubre su talento
al combinar los sabores se expresará en
lo culinario y quien gusta de los
colores la música las formas se
manifestará a través del arte y quien ha
descubierto su vocación en la
experimentación podría hacerlo en la
ciencia de la ingeniería y por qué no
alguien podría combinar todas estas
habilidades y crear negocios innovadores
brindar respuestas diferentes a
problemas cotidianos oa problemas más
complejos
la manifestación del propio talento es
tan importante hoy en día porque impacta
directamente en la productividad y
competitividad de las empresas y las
naciones de todo el mundo
el índice global de la competitividad
del talento creado por adecco la escuela
de negocios insead y google en su
versión 2020 destaca países como suiza
singapur
eeuu como aquellos que tienen mayor
capacidad de gestionar su talento y esto
es gracias a estrategias de facilitación
de desarrollo de retención del talento
y este resultado nos ayuda a formular
una gran pregunta
a quién le falta el resto que le hace
falta hacer
la empresa rights management en su
estudio la gestión humana como punto
clave en el desempeño empresarial
realizado en 13 países reveló que sólo
el 42 por ciento de empresas admitieron
tener programas para el desarrollo
organizacional al interior de sus
empresas y el 38 por ciento expresó que
únicamente
desarrollaba a los colaboradores que
mostraban interés en su talento
y esta información
simplemente nos deja claro que hay
muchas personas que se quedan al margen
con su talento encajonado haciendo
funciones muy repetitivas y sin
probabilidad de crecimiento
obviamente este es un proceso de
conciencia ni las empresas ni los países
pueden preocuparse por el desarrollo del
capital humano si las mismas personas no
se dan a la tarea por descubrir su
talento por hacerse cuestionamientos
importantes
esto nos muestra cuán limitado puede ser
el valor que le asignamos al desarrollo
de nuestro propio potencial
cuán limitada puede estar nuestra
capacidad de hacer tecnología
la mayoría de las personas nos hemos
encontrado alguna vez en ese territorio
oscuro de la no manifestación de la no
generación de recursos propios
observándome a mí misma y acompañando a
otros en el desarrollo de su talento me
he dado cuenta que es muy fácil que
vayamos a aprender conocimientos
hipótesis experimentos creados por
alguien más comprobados por alguien más
y luego aplicarlos a nuestra vida
y muy difícilmente vamos hacia la
experimentación
hacia el descubrimiento de sí
hemos sido educados para ser
replicadores no manifestadores
en lo personal
fui por muchos años una experta
replicadora de los aprendizajes y
versiones del mundo de los adultos que
me rodeaban de sus formatos de
comportamiento e incluso de aquellos
talentos que ellos querían ver en mí
y era muy fácil acomodarse a lo que ya
estaba dado y comprobado no había como
nada que despertar a mi curiosidad nada
por descubrir y lo interesante acá es
que todo estaba bien porque era lo
correcto
este fue mi entrenamiento para la cndh o
manifestación
hasta que me canse y a los 18 años me
mudé para el extranjero
con el deseo de ser diferente y
construir mi historia alejada de la
estructura que me rodeaba aún tengo
clara la imagen de mis padres diciendo
adiós y yo sintiendo esa firme
convicción que al final de ese camino me
esperaba la libertad
y no me lo van a creer
y terminé replicando otro modelo de vida
preconcebido
y es que no importaba a dónde iba y
volvía a replicar
parecía que era vocacional replicar
parecía que no había nada más
hasta que decidí quedarme quieta
agradecer a mis grandes maestros y decir
a partir de aquí sigo yo
dentro de mí sentía algo moviéndose
queriendo salir eran mis talentos dando
su ultimátum
en este punto el ser humano tiene dos
caminos
confinadas en la profundidad aquello que
incomoda a su comodidad
o revelar verdaderamente lo que es sin
cláusulas y condiciones
el hacer tecnología y dar el salto de la
no manifestación a la manifestación
plena significa quedarse quieto un
momento para hacer ese viaje
introspectivo
y reconocer de qué estamos hechos
lo que aprendimos en la escuela en la
universidad de nuestros grandes maestros
deja de gobernar nuestra vida para
constituir la red de nuestros recursos
personales y al identificar cada uno de
nuestros talentos estos se convierten en
los nodos que unifican la red
el talento ya ha significado en la red
y la sostiene
es así como nace nuestra propia
tecnología
y este juego de la manifestación tiene
como escenario la propia vida y ésta no
es más que un laboratorio experimental
donde vas y compruebas algunas hipótesis
que responden a la pregunta qué tal sí
y en este laboratorio comienzas a
sumergirte en la realidad
a conocer diversas maneras de expresarte
porque no sólo ayuda hay muchas
dimensiones que explorar
por ejemplo un comunicador talentoso
pudiese expresarse como un gran orador
youtuber profesor poeta cantante
o combinar todas estas formas de
expresión
de repente tu talento se vuelve
multidimensional y él quiere es el poder
de patentar nuevas formas de ser y hacer
y mientras haces tu propia tecnología
trasciendes
empiezas a conectar con el entorno y a
visualizar oportunidades que antes no
veías
comienzas a conectar con otras personas
y con su tecnología
encontrando le sentido a la co-creación
siendo un actor importante de la
transformación de la sociedad
a esto
es algo que los griegos llamaron
tecnología el tipo de tecnología que te
hace real y significativo
te preguntarás por qué es importante
todo esto
ahora tras el avance tecnológico el
cambio climático y el kobe 19 la energía
del planeta se mueve hacia la innovación
social
exigiendo el talento que necesita para
dinamizar y transformar la realidad
inmersa en continuos desafíos y
problemas que resolver
sin embargo esto es imposible de
realizar con seres humanos limitados con
creencias
que deseen poder han y con esta fe
puesta en algo que debe de ocurrir allá
afuera
es imposible con personas que desconocen
su propio talento su propio poder de
producir su tecnología
bienvenidos a la era de la tecnología
del talento cuéntanos quién eres
ayúdanos a resolver hitos como el de la
pobreza desigualdad
el estancamiento
bienvenidos a la era de la tecnología
del talento en donde la moneda es tu
talento y la fuente generadora
eres tú
[Música]